good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
feels like a little delayed like
Friday's like halfway done already by
the time we record this we are recording
a little delayed today we are but I did
like Friday The Abridged version by
turdy Lou
Friday Taylor's no Friday turdy's
version it always is
so you know what is is today is Friday
which is just fabulous news it doesn't
feel like a real Friday because we had a
short week so it feels like we almost
don't even deserve this Friday does
anybody else feel that way is that true
this was a short week
it was Memorial day you're so right
honestly this was a very long week for
me yeah like you had like a bunch of
doctors appointments that's why we are
late today apologies for the late
recurting with ricardia and Jax but
Jackie had a bunch of doctor's
appointments this morning and your
girlie attended them and I have a lot of
thought Claudia was my companion what
were your thoughts on the whole scene at
the OB well my first thought was like I
just kind of felt like I was like
walking in the shoes I really thought
everyone in the in the office thought we
were a couple because we look more like
lesbian a lesbian couple than we do
sisters we look nothing alike people why
can't we be friends
I just feel like friends don't take each
other to their appointments I know but I
feel like we were acting more like
friends and less cuddly like we were
cracking up I feel like couples really
don't do that definitely not at that
point like in pregnancy well it just
kind of felt exciting like to to just
like have people see me through a new
lens like I'm just a partner you know
I'm a supportive partner yeah you were a
supportive partner that's facts and
obviously I went because I love you
dearly and you know Zach had to watch
Harry so of course I would come had I
known that you had an appointment at
like this Imaging thing right across the
street from what will now be like moving
forward my favorite place on the planet
I would have I would come to all of your
appointments since you came to New York
like we were getting hungry it was long
by the way we were there for like three
hours you had like a bunch of different
appointments
and at one point I think I mentioned you
know lunch afterwards and you were like
why don't you run across the street
there's like some restaurants go get us
some food so I was like oh okay and I
just kind of stumbled into this place
and I didn't realize as I was walking in
that it was a zabars you know a New York
classic there's like 15 of them in the
city and you know every time anybody
like writes a book or makes a movie
about New York it's like zabar zabar
Zabar's fresh bread so I'm like ashamed
to admit that as a New Yorker but more
importantly as a Jew I had never been
I had never been to zabars and I had
such an unbelievable experience I felt
like the main character in a Nancy Myers
movie I like wanted to get a baguette
and just wear a beret and like walk
around this little Bistro it was I was
overwhelmed first of all by the options
like the fresh bread fresh pastries
uh Bagels it was like 11 so we were
going like breakfast yeah but then I saw
like the hot food selection I saw you
know delicious looking rice I saw
chicken tenders do you see things in
which to make turdies warm bowls I did
it was kind of like a warm Bowl Haven if
you will
and I just I felt like a better version
of myself like I my new kind of Life
goal is to be the girl that was in the
market like I was just kind of sashaying
around you know looking at the baguettes
I felt like seriously I came back and I
said to Jackie that I felt like Meryl
Streep's character and it's complicated
because she owns this like major French
Marketplace Bakery where they like have
fresh espresso and baguettes and
croissant every day
and I know people who live in New York
are like oh my God this [__] is not
making a 40 minute podcast about zabars
but like I am I had never been I haven't
been in a really long time like not old
enough to appreciate it if I've ever
really even stepped in I feel like I've
only ever gotten like their crackers
we're gonna have to go after my next
doctor's appointment like I'll let Zach
know that you have to be there and we'll
have to go and have the full experience
like for a lunch a meal we can sit and
dine in yes it had like these gorgeous
very French inspired like boots and Bank
cats but it wasn't big and it wasn't
busy it was like and it was like almost
lunch a rush but it was in a very quiet
neighborhood so it wasn't overwhelming
there's some really nice places and you
want to like spend your afternoon there
but they're so busy that you just like
get in and get out no not Zay bars it
was like a culinary experience I swear
to God when I stepped out I was like I
am in France like it was so elevated so
you took a trip to France this morning
pretty much Bon wee turdy Lou
I'm honestly jealous I'm wishing that I
had that experience and walked in and
you would like never know it because we
just got like bagels with cream cheese
which yeah I honestly
like I fumbled in terms of the actual
purchasing but it was like a weird time
it was 11 15. it's not lunch yeah you
could have gotten us our lunches too
because we would have been ready for
lunch in like one hour later I didn't
know that we were gonna be at this
doctor's appointment literally till one
o'clock I thought we were almost done
honestly we
but it was just like almost done is
still long no no we we came in there for
three things like an Imaging a shot and
one other thing and it was an hour per
thing like it was just slow and you have
to like start when you do one thing then
go back to the waiting room yeah go
through it again like the way that a
doctor's appointment is an hour when you
try and do like three things in one
doctor's appointment it's three hours
but going to these like fertility like
doctors did remind me of the first time
I went to like an appointment for my
wedding planning because I remember when
I let me explain I remember when I like
started meeting with like you know at
wedding dress shops and planners I
remember being so like taken aback by
how everyone who works in the bridal
industry was so nice and they were like
so excited about your wedding like just
as excited as you were like they really
the people who work in the bridal
industry like make it special they
really do a good job and I was thinking
today like everyone we met like that
nurse who we were chatting with at the
end and then that lady in the waiting
room and then the other girl who did
like your cervix thing in the sonogram
she was everyone was so nice and like so
cared so much about you you and like
we're like doing you know the most like
let me just oh I got the images but let
me just make sure like everyone was
doing their jobs like so well and they
were so nice it was mostly women it was
just kind of like a great energy it's a
great community
it is but I've never been apart because
obviously I've never been well at the
Imaging Center I'm glad that you had a
good experience and like witnessing the
behind the scenes of like Pregnancy Care
no it's really like I think it's called
neonatal
is it no that's like for babies no
but isn't it like like neonatal care I
mean I guess it's like women's health
but also Women's Health I think the word
is just pregnancy
okay well Pregnancy Care obstetrics
obstetrics yeah but you could also be
going in for a pap smear and that's
obstetrics like I mean like pregnant
women care okay fertility pregnant women
care no fertility is a different sect
oh okay well whoever everyone who works
there was just like [__] nice and I
really appreciated it I'm so glad you
had such a positive morning with your
girl I did and you were being such a
good sis really did me a solid it was
also nice because you know I have kind
of like a brain for Science and an
aptitude for medicine so it was just
kind of nice to get another opinion in
there and be like yeah I know that
Imaging looks it looks good you were
pleased with what you saw Carrie I was
pleased with yeah no I was monitoring
you know I didn't want to point out when
they were doing things wrong I was
monitoring and you know what they did
good you did good
so it was nice and I just loved that
market yeah I'm honestly like hungry
again
I don't know we like really I really
[__] up like in terms of what I
purchased I so like [__] the bed I was
honestly you could have like grocery
shopped for us I know there was like a
big challah that I really wanted to get
I just didn't know if I could come back
to the doctor's office for like shopping
bags like I think it would have been the
life of the party
I know because we did get like a bunch
of food and we didn't eat all of it but
we were giving it away to the other
pregnant ladies in the waiting room I
was talking she was like I'm so hungry
but I didn't want to be late for my
appointment I was like do you want half
my bagel and she took it it's a
collective in there no I'm telling you
like the way that waiting room was never
as Lively as it was today like Jackson
Claude need a permanent residency in
that waiting it's true it's I've been in
that waiting room a bunch it's never
really popping like that and I feel like
is this place for high-risk pregnancies
yes not exclusively because I also went
there um in my pregnancy with Harry but
they do focus on high risk so you know
morale can be low in a waiting room like
that and I think that they need to bring
us in like on a bi-weekly basis yeah and
they need to bring you in you made the
difference I'm always there I guess I
could bring my guitar and do like my
Miss Rachel impersonation you should go
to a daycare and do that I know if you
know if podcasting doesn't work out for
me I've taken Harry to like a bunch of
those music classes like that's
definitely a job I am well suited for no
like when people ask you if you weren't
a podcaster what would you be like
that's your answer Children's Group
musician yeah like those classes like at
the kids gyms and stuff where somebody
walks around with a guitar and sings
like twinkle twinkle but they always put
like they always have Flair those people
always have Charisma yeah we have talent
I feel like that's a job I'm extremely
well suited for it except I feel like
it's a lot of time on my feet you why
not sit no one said you have to stand
yeah mine would kind of be like the low
energy meditation class yeah or you do
it with a partner I think you'd be
really good with Ben and he can make the
rounds and he needs to pick up an
instrument to make pass out the scarves
he could pass out the scarves and you
know the little Maracas yeah yeah yeah
I it's a really good future for you guys
if you if your future as a cantorial Duo
doesn't work out no it's just a backup
plan it's so important to like always
have different options in life you never
know what gonna happen yeah and in the
meantime Harry's loves your talents and
services right now I perform for an
audience of one and I'm genuinely okay
with that but like he literally is
obsessed
obsessed Jackson I spent the whole day
together yesterday which was fabulous
dude we were so Willy Wonka in bed
together all day Claudia got me a TV
well okay let's talk about that Jackie's
fully like on [__] bed rest out here
without a [__] TV in her bedroom like
are you okay I ordered one on shout out
to Costco instacart 200 granted it was a
brand I had never heard of it wasn't
like a Sony or a Samsung or an LG who
cares 200 for a 55 inch TV that got
delivered in an hour on Costco instacart
we set it up we got our Roku set we
watched Kardashians in bed like I cannot
believe you're out here like bed resting
without a TV you're seriously not okay
no I know well there's just always so
much going on in my house that like
either I'm on my computer working or I'm
just like texting it on my phone or I am
reading so it's like I hadn't noticed
yet
look at that how annoying it is to not
have a TV but now that I have one like
I'm addicted and now I need to find a
show to binge I'm thinking Desperate
Housewives again
there's never a bad time to restart
Desperate Housewives that's just kind of
like a life lesson I think everyone
should abide bye
uh agreed
um I also told Jackie that she should
start watching what did I tell you when
we were scrolling on the show that's
weeds yeah they have a lot of Seasons
it's like funny it's I think it's pretty
light-hearted I don't think it gets like
too dark and it's cute I think you would
like a lot I remember I tried to start
it once a million years ago and I wasn't
into it but maybe now I would be like as
a mom I think it's about like a mom who
sells drugs yeah she just like gets into
the weed business because she's like
falling upon tough times and then of
course over the course of like 10
seasons she gets carried away yeah yeah
so I feel like that could be more my
speed now just like Suburban Drama Oh
and it's very Suburban drama so maybe
it's my time
could be but we watched a lot of TV
yesterday we watched Kardashians and
then we both watched a bunch of episodes
of that smartless show which were just
like intrigued by we're so intrigued by
and like I've we were watching at the
same time separately and we were just
like texting each other because there
were a couple things that were actually
kind of shocking
uh yeah the MIT guy the second Boston
performance where they completely for
those oh I guess for people who spoil it
okay wait but no but that's not I was
gonna say oh for people who like don't
know what we're talking about basically
the smartless podcast has a documentary
that like documents their entire podcast
tour and on their tour they have like a
special guest come to every show
but the cool thing is that the audience
doesn't know who the guest is going to
be and neither do two out of three of
the hosts every show one of the hosts
will invite someone and then bring them
on stage and like everyone's really
shocked it's a really cool concept I
actually like it
um so the first two shows were uh chosen
by Will Arnett Will Arnett brought
um will David Letterman and will no no
no Will Ferrell and Conan O'Brien yeah
so like major comedy if you're into
Jason Bateman Will Arnett and Sean Hayes
then these are your kings
so then for the next two shows um Jason
Bateman was in charge of selecting a
guess and I would argue that out of the
three of them Jason Bateman is the most
famous so I was ready to be dazzled and
he's bringing out the guest he's giving
like an intro and honestly the way he's
describing it I thought he was going to
bring out Elon Musk he was talking about
how smart this guy is how he teaches at
MIT how he's responsible for the quantum
physics of the universe like all this
stuff and then he says the guy's name
Max something tag Mark yeah who's just
like a really really really really smart
probably one of the smartest people in
the world who like works at MIT
um who cares yeah it was it was so
awkward like we watched we watched the
tour like the actual show it was like
awkward it was awkward and Not only was
the guest like not what Buzzy and what
people wanted especially since like
right before that was Conan so I think
on Twitter everyone was talking about
like we had Conan tonight so then the
second show was like oh my God who are
we getting right and they got Max
tegmark who is not an a star or like a
A-list traditional celebrity and he's
not a podcaster either so like not only
was it like oh I don't know that I want
to hear about AI but now I'm hearing a
conversation about AI That's like not
that like entertaining funny it was not
entertaining when they got off stage
they like didn't know if they had done a
bad job at first and then the more they
talked about it like they knew and then
the next morning they woke up and there
was just like so much backlash from
their fans because like people are
paying for tickets and for someone to
get to see David Letterman and then
someone else to see like Max tegmark and
no no no there's not any hate no he's a
genius he's just not entertaining like I
want to go to a comedy show to go see a
physicist
um
and it was just kind of awkward
especially because I I really expected
the most from Jason mayman and then his
next guest was AOC and some people had
complained about that and I was just
like what is with I would have thought
Jason Bateman would have brought like
the most funny the most famous the most
interesting not like two boring ones
yeah well I feel like
it's crazy that they only started their
podcast in 2020 and it's clear that like
they know what they're doing they're
extremely successful they have this
format so I have two things to say this
format that you know one person brings
on the guests the other two don't know
who it is and a conversation comes from
there which is really cute it's like the
mystery guest and it works great on a
podcast because if you're a podcast
listener and they bring out a guest that
you don't really want to hear like okay
I'm just not listening today like not a
big deal but when you buy a ticket for a
show you're spending your money and then
you also have to sit there for two hours
and you're listening to someone that you
don't like are not entertained by
whatsoever like the a concept of a
mystery that's like doesn't really work
when you're selling tickets unless now
they just commit to every guest being
just like a fellow comedian that they
know that their guests are gonna love
but I do feel like Jason Bateman like
wants to take this show in more of like
uh Joe Rogan Direction where we're
having like intellectual interlections
and we're not just like a bunch of
comics sitting around but the thing is
your audience wants to see a bunch of
comics sitting around like if they
wanted to hear about Ai and science like
they might listen to a different podcast
yeah no he just like takes himself a
little seriously but I feel like he's
also trying to still carve out what the
show could be and I feel like we do that
it's natural to like change and stuff
and like want to be more than what
you're doing I just like wouldn't
experiment on a live show yeah yeah no
it's it's very interesting to watch it's
not like what I thought it would be like
every show is just like a banger there's
like highs and lows
they're getting like a little sick of
each other because they're they're
non-stop they're it's not like they go
home in between like they're literally
on a plane and a tour bus and like
they're just maybe like and they're
choosing to share a room
which I thought was so interesting that
they're not getting their own hotel
rooms now it's not like two queen beds
in a regular these are the craziest
hotel rooms I've ever seen in my life
they're like four bedrooms they
literally don't end
they're so big like Sean kept getting
lost at the in the room like they're so
big I find the logistics of how they
travel really interesting yeah also
it's only a 10 City tour right
I don't know I think that it is like
it's not you know eras
no but it's still like two weeks living
in the same room as two other people and
you're like a grown man yeah they could
get their own rooms
yeah
but they don't want to it's interesting
no no it's very interesting it's very
good I really like it I was also really
shocked to learn that their podcast only
started in 2020 for me they're just like
one of those OG podcast like they're
always at the top of the comedy chart I
just assumed that they were seriously
like a
just like a staple in in the podcast
community no I knew that they were
fresher but that like there were a lot
of podcasts that popped up during covet
especially celebrity podcasts that like
petered off maybe even quit but or or
are just like respectable in the top 200
whatever
um but that they really made it like and
they obviously have something that
people really like yeah yeah they they
have some they have like a star Factor
like they're but I'm like watching their
show like the even the live show and
like their people are laughing in the
crowd and like I'm not laughing like
humorous I don't think we're the target
demo no but Zach's cracking up no
exactly
Zach is definitely Target demo yeah he
is so it's just interesting but I do I
find the whole concept interesting there
are parts that are more boring than
other parts but I think the interesting
Parts make it worth the boring Parts
yeah and it's just Rising Tides rise all
shy it's like this is a great moment for
podcasting it is a great moment for
podcasting and it also makes me think
about like other like the scale of other
podcasts like yeah I would love to see
more of this type of content
of like on the road with a podcast yeah
I mean the scale of their podcast and
their tour I don't think is predicated
on the scale of their podcast I think
it's predicated on the scale of their
celebrity I do agree because even people
who have podcasts bigger than smart
lists go on tour and they don't take
private planes but these are three
people who are very independently
wealthy yeah and famous
I agree with that maybe it wouldn't be
as interesting to watch I don't know
yeah if it was just a couple of
podcasters
but it's nice I like that HBO is doing
something different like it's cool yeah
but that's a good precedent
oh
so
now that we've
chatted
at length about Tings I've been getting
like [__] for how I say length oh
welcome to the club of getting [__] for
how you say things I say like length I
do say the g it I'm Never Gonna Knock
someone for pronouncing things as
they're spelled
I'm just a phonetic Queen and that's
something I have to live with you're
hooked on phonetics I'm hooked on
phonetics and zabars and toast
and you oh and me with you and Bryson
streis of course NK levitson and rodini
of course and our husbands who we love
of course we love them so much we put
them last The Best For Last surely
okay well without further Ado let us get
into the fast five stories that you need
to know because the stories are storying
today and we've got to get into them
well the story is storying are brought
to you by the Kardashians on Hulu watch
the all new seasons of the Kardashians
new episodes Thursday only on Hulu the
world's most famous matriarchy is back
for the most intimate look yet inside
the family Empire this season the women
work to strike a balance between their
extremely successful lives as business
women and their very real personal lives
we've got entrepreneurship sibling
rivalry Newfound love family growth
juggling business motherhood family and
more Jax and I were able to catch up
yesterday on her new TV and it was a
very very wonderful experience watching
my favorite family with my favorite
family you know it's kind of meta like
that um
it was a really good episode we got a
lot of Kylie all the girls are in the
show of course we've got Queen Chris
Courtney Kim Chloe Kendall Kylie all the
girls are showing up and showing out
this season there's so much
um
so many good storylines but they're also
just so many characters in the show
obviously beyond the the original
girlies like fan favorites Scott
um Travis we're getting to see everyone
and it's really fabulous so the new
episodes of the Kardashians drop on Hulu
there are new episodes every Thursday
again they're only available on Hulu
this is season three I think it's gonna
be one of their best seasons yet it's
really good the production quality is
also so fabulous like their little
Montage in the beginning when they all
went roller skating big budget it looks
really good don't miss season three of
the Kardashians new episodes Thursday
only on Hulu today's episode is also
brought to you by Lululemon specifically
they're fabulous shorts for summer their
shorts were made to stretch flex and
support the infinite ways of working out
giving you the courage to LEAP into
something totally new and unexpected so
some of our favorite shorts from
Lululemon shorts are the hottie hot
shorts and that's their short with a
comfortable range of motion and a
flattering fit they allow you to Max
your stride so you can move freely with
confidence the lightweight Swift fabric
lets in airflow so you you can move
without baggage they're designed to Wick
away sweat before you even notice that
it's there we also love the Wonder train
short so it's the short with super
supportive stretch that allows you to
stay dry it's powered by the everlux
fabric the Wonder train collection
manages heat and sweat so you stay stay
comfortable and you stay focused also
for any of our male listeners or a few
ladies have a man in your life who loves
to wear athletic wear or works out a lot
the pace breaker short are fabulous Ben
loves them they're really versatile the
lightweight fabric means that you can
train move and stretch however you want
to every pair of pace breaker shorts is
designed to Wick away moisture so all
that's left is your intention
so uh Lululemon is the place to shop for
anything in terms of athletic wear and
their shorts are here just in time for
summer it is so hot outside so whether
you're working out or just running
errands you don't want to have like that
moist undercarriage we have to protect
our crevices we have to protect our
undercarriage so you can get into the
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-u-l-e-m-o-n.com lululemon.com
thank you Claudia yeah well so if you
had to sum up the first two sponsors
would you say that it's hululemon
I would say it's hululemon hululemon.com
undercarriage exactly
okay our first story I'm
UPS Beyond Kylie Jenner and Timothy
chalamet were seen together for the
first time with their famous sisters
literally
sorry I'll allow you to finish please
save your thoughts till the end the
rumored couple Kylie and Timothy appear
to have taken the next step in their
relationship meeting each other's
families so they were photographed
together for the first time lingling
with each other's relatives at a
barbecue earlier this month there have
been rumors that they've been spotted
together we've seen her car in his
driveway we've seen them like both be in
the same restaurant but we've not gotten
a frame of the two of them together in
frame and these photos which were taken
like by some creep at a bird's eye view
are very very revealing in the sense
that these people are all hanging out
yeah no it was extremely revealing to me
there's two major takeaways from this
and I just want to say so Kylie brought
her sister who we know Kendall and
Timothy brought his sister who we know
Pauline because she is Kimberly on sex
lives of college girls and when I first
saw the headline that he's with his
sister I'm like oh the sister but then I
when I remembered who the sister was I
was like the sister so that was my first
takeaway like we have to acknowledge the
the Kimberly of it all Kimberly from sex
lives of college girls is probably one
of my favorite characters like ever
created in the television Universe she's
so [__] weird and funny and she's
just everything of the sort so the fact
that like think of it as like Kimberly
hanging out with them and it just it
changes things it's so fabulous and the
second for me like this story is a
bombshell not because it's showing
pictures of Kylie and Timothy chalamet
but because it's showing Kylie holding a
pack of Marlboro Lights and an ashtray
like Kylie is a cigarette smoker I think
I might have known that like I think
I've seen a photo of her with a
cigarette like once or twice but I
forgot and I can't get over it no I
didn't know this
um the only thing I'll say is like
either she's obviously like a pack a day
JoJo siwa smoking like that or she's
like carrying her man's cigs because I
could see two definitely does being into
cigarettes or she's like gotten into
cigarettes because of him but as much as
I never expected this from her
it tracks
no by the way there are like three
paparazzi photos on the internet yeah
she was like 18 I think the other one
from when she was like a few years ago
she doesn't say no to a cigarette but
maybe she was celebrating her Newfound
love yeah but there's a difference
between like being 18 and like being
crazy with a cigarette versus like oh
it's daytime and we're hanging out I
must have a cigarette I must have my
pack and on me with my personal ashtray
no okay so like having a personal
ashtray I think takes us to like another
level of like smoker or she was just
like bringing out the barbecue Tings to
the table including like an ashtray for
the group and my boyfriend sigs
well a lot of people were like oh Chris
Jenner works hard the devil works hard
or whatever like Christian are set up
these photos for the family and NT
tweeted and I thought it was a really
good point like yeah Christian I'm sure
sometimes she does that but like she
would never have sanctioned photos of
Kylie with cigarettes like there's like
this is so not a setup it's so real
and I appreciate the reality of the
situation and the cigarettes of the
situation like it's just which sister
was she with Kendall Kendall
do you think candle's smoking too like
it's such a it's such a model thing to
do like oh we're hungry oh that's like
that Tick Tock sound so for breakfast we
have a cigarette and a little bar of
chocolate like it's so like you know
health and her cryo chamber remember
that episode where she was like talking
about how she's so weirdly obsessed with
health you know that's so that person
like doesn't smoke cigarettes
yeah but I feel like that person is
actually really Courtney
no Courtney is like an extreme for sure
like but I saw a Courtney with a
cigarette like I my mind would be blown
I would be shocked but I think Kendall
falls into that category a little bit of
like
matcha
tea
rejuvenate relax repeat wait total weird
tangent and I know you know nothing
about this do you have any idea what's
going on with the Phillips Schofield
drama I've never heard that name okay so
Phillip Schofield was on like the um
biggest Morning Show in Britain like
you've probably seen you've probably
seen clips of like him and his female
co-hosts are like always cackling
together he's kind of like a staple of
British media and a few weeks ago like
some big Scandal came out about him he
was like having an inappropriate
relationship like people are really
upset because he was like really in
millions and millions of homes for like
so many years and it's blown the network
wide open whatever and I don't know like
everything about it but today I saw all
over Tick Tock he did his first
interview and he's talking about how
he's like been so depressed yada yada
um but he's using a vape the entire time
he's in this like really serious
sit-down interview with like a 60
Minutes equivalent and he's vaping this
like Turk bright blue turquoise babe
like in between questions it is the
weirdest thing that's so weird but he's
able to do a Morning Show for years and
not Vape right
maybe he's just spiraling clearly like
he was saying some of them really absurd
[__] no I didn't know about any of that
and honestly it sounds like I didn't
like I don't need to now know you know
it's not like you're so obsessed with
the bridge it's not like em
you needed to know about Ian Tonga yeah
no I was I don't think you need to know
about this but I just wonder if anyone
else listening to this podcast has
fallen into the Phillip Schofield Tick
Tock drama but it's not even Tick Tock
drama I'm just learning about it on Tick
Tock he very much like operates on like
traditional media yeah it's Morning Show
British drama playing out it's morning
it's Morning Show British drama playing
out on Tick Tock I actually I love that
rabbit hole for you I won't stop you
well back to the task at hand so we can
confirm that Kylie and Timothy are a
couple it's not the couple I would
choose for her
it's not the couple I would choose for
me but I'm happy for my girl
yeah Timothy Shellman is just not really
ever someone I'm gonna be attracted to
and maybe there's something wrong with
me or there's something wrong with
everyone else but it's just it's gonna
be a no for me but I'm so happy for
Kylie yep so it's like I just wouldn't
pair him with my number one girl like
but if he if he was like spotted dating
someone else who I'm like who I care
about the same level the same like I'd
be more here for it but for my number
one girl like I want her with my number
one guy that didn't happen which is who
who's your number one guy oh Jason Momoa
Kylie and Josh Groban Josh Groban has a
girlfriend
he does I've actually recently started
following Josh Groban on Instagram since
he responded to one of my Instagram
stories um that I tagged him in like
many moons ago and he's such a hard
worker he's on Broadway right now in
Sweeney Todd he's he's really living
like he's very fulfilled you should be
happy for sure but like he doesn't have
a choice other than to share his gift
with the world like it wouldn't be true
right it's almost a burden yeah no it
wouldn't be right if he just like stayed
home and took time off it's like well
what about your angelic voice no it
wouldn't be right if he just like worked
in marketing and had like this cool
party trick where he happened to sing
really good like yeah no like he needs
to be constantly sharing his gift with
the world like God gave you a gift now
share it you're so right and I'm sure he
feels that pressure but it sounds like
he's rising to the occasion you know who
else would do that Kylie we have never
seen Josh Groban perform live have we
like in person no I remember one of his
concerts there were a couple tours of
his that I really wanted to go to it
like didn't work out like I remember he
had a show on my birthday or something
and I wasn't going to be here like I've
actually really tried and I think I'd
given up
okay well I'm gonna put that on like my
list of things to get you in like future
years because also he's the kind of guy
who goes on a tour like for a specific
album where it could be like a collab
album he did like some random album
recently and it's like so he's not
playing the hits
yeah
you know yeah that's that's tough like
we need a Josh Groban greatest hits tour
yeah we do I'll be front row Center
that's kind of what's so fabulous not to
bring everything back to Taylor but
that's really what's so fabulous about
the era's tour it's really a greatest
hits tour true and speaking of Taylor
our next two stories are Taylor adjacent
Taylor is involved in the next two
stories but not it's actually not about
the era's tour so everyone will be happy
to hear about that okay first story
Forbes has put out their list of
America's richest self-made women and
obviously we're most interested in the
celebrities who made the list and Taylor
Swift is now the second richest
self-made woman in music but still kind
of far off from being number one that
place is held by Rihanna who is worth
over two billion two billion yeah yeah I
just want to say and this is not me just
being like a Taylor apologist I don't
really feel like it's fair for Rihanna
to be on the music list because
Rihanna's Fortune comes from business
which is so impressive but they should
be on different lists they are Forbes
put out this huge list it's like a
database and honestly in the top 10 top
20 I don't know one of these people's
names it's not just like Oprah and
Taylor and Kim and Beyonce but if you
search by category by Source the source
of their income Rihanna is under music
and cosmetics okay Taylor's under music
um what about Kim and Kylie Kylie is
under Cosmetics Kim is under she's not
under fashion she's under oh shapewear
and skin care it's so specific oh they
went real specifically no there's
literally a category called Spanx and
it's just Sarah Blakely
dead yeah so I think all the
Publications have broken out this list
into the people that we know and made
like the top 10 celebrity list which is
of course interesting
um but it's not like just comparing like
Rihanna and Taylor their sources were
different as noted by Forbes yeah yeah
no and I think a lot of people were
really interested in the tailor of it
all because this year was probably the
year she becomes a billionaire because
the tour will gross over a billion
dollars and at the time of this
publication what would they say her net
worth was 7 40. 740.
social most likely become a billionaire
this year after the tour wraps and all
the merch and all the songs
um which is just oh and she also I speak
now like she'll definitely become
a billionaire this year which is so
crazy that she's like not already yeah
it's also always crazy to me that
Beyonce is not I think she's like a 500
million
yeah uh I will say Taylor definitely had
like a leg up it's the second she
started making money because her dad
like literally did it for a living like
investment baking and then I think his
full-time job became like handling her
money and so she's like always been
really really smart about her money
before she started making serious dough
so you know you got to start him young
yeah she also passed Madonna who has 580
million and Kylie's on the list she is
at 680 million which is interesting
because like Forbes once called her like
self-made billionaire also it's
interesting that they put Kylie on this
list they're sticking by their title of
self-made self-made really appreciate
them being scrupled about that no people
got like so in the Weeds about that
because self-made when it comes to
millionaire means not inherited like
there's a list of the world's richest
women and the top 10 are either
heiresses or widows like they're or
divorce divorces yeah like there is a
difference
it's Kylie Cosmetics like it's your
company yeah she grew up very privileged
that still makes you self-made sorry
yeah no it's crazy and the for the top
20 are all like women in business
they're a lot older who's the richest
woman in the world like she's number one
oh in the country
oh country Diane Hendricks at 15 billion
she her sources Building Supplies she
owns like the biggest Roofing Supply
Company
I'm telling you like if you want to get
rich in this country like you have to do
the most [__] obscure jobs it's never
like banking it's always like yeah I
invented the patent for like the light
bulb or whatever number two her source
is gas stations
we love a gassy Queen number three her
source is Healthcare software that'll do
it that'll do it
yeah so it's a very interesting list I'm
happy for everyone who's charting
it's inspiring I hope to be on that list
one day and Kim is over a billion
that's well skims really
um in the last few years people don't
even talk enough like skims is
probably more successful obviously than
kkw beauty or Kylie Cosmetics even at
Kylie's Peak like skims is really it's
become a verb not a verb a noun the way
that like when people put on shapewear
they say I'm putting on Spanx like now
they also say I'm putting on skims like
it's really become ubiquitous yeah also
what I thought was interesting I forgot
what category she's under but I was
looking through the categories and you
know who's there at like 300 million or
280 million
um
Emma greed who's their business partner
yeah
that's great she's very very smart
police skims and good American
yeah and I'm sure she has like other
businesses that made her qualified to be
that partner
oh you know who's on here under skin
care
Kathy fields and Katie Rhoden of Rhoden
and Fields
Say It Ain't So a couple MLM Queens it's
a really interesting list
no it is I I gotta dive in deep yeah
they make it an easy database except
like they really should do a list of
names that you've heard of
yeah but no I do I do find it really
interesting how like non-famous people
become so wealthy like and what do they
do for a living yeah not all of us can
sing you know for our supper yeah do you
remember when we were in Turks and
Caicos um we did like a jet ski tour and
like we were saying at this house and a
few houses down was like the biggest
house we'd ever seen in our whole lives
and the guy's like so famous on the
island everyone knows him I think he's
from the UK and we're like how did he
get so rich he like has a patent on a
type of door it's always like the most
obscure [__]
we need to invent a door turdy Lou
I know I just feel like the door is like
it's like been already invented you know
yeah
it's tough
we'll figure it out we'll think about it
we'll think about it patreon episode
redesigning coming up with ideas for how
to become billionaires our next episode
a little Taylor adjacent news but not
totally focused on Taylor is that Taylor
is bringing Sabrina Carpenter on the
Eris tour amid Olivia Rodrigo Feud
rumors so Taylor just dropped her
International dates but just South
America not like Europe or anything
right no and she said more International
tour dates are coming and there have
been like rumors about Brazil
specifically so I guess she's rolling it
out in waves this one is like very South
America yeah she's going to Brazil
Argentina and Mexico and one of her
opening acts is Sabrina Carpenter which
you know she loves to support a young
female talent burgeoning but it's
notable because Sabrina the Olivia was
the great Feud of 2021 and Taylor was
really quite close with Olivia yeah
they've tapered off a little bit and now
Sabrina's here what does it mean turdy
no it's interesting especially because
for the the American eras tour it was
like a full lineup there were like three
Acts Gail Phoebe Bridgers
maybe there was just two but so Sabrina
Carpenter is getting like a the full VIP
there's only one and she's at every show
that's a kind of major for Sabrina now
this is interesting like I'm I'm I hate
to like like look for something when
maybe there's nothing there but I do
think there's something here the way
that like Olivia Rodrigo popped off and
Taylor like immediately supported her
because Olivia Rodrigo is the biggest
Swifty and then Taylor released um
Fearless Taylor's version and had Olivia
Rodrigo and Conan gray make tick tocks
with the tracks to promote it like they
were so tight like and so publicly on
social media like supporting one another
and like I don't know
something about this is weird the way
that like they they did that and then
stopped like acknowledging each other
publicly is so weird and now the Sabrina
Carpenter of it all is also weird yeah
but I was saying to
prize I mean like I feel like Taylor is
more
oh I'm gonna shut out ice out the girl
who stole your boyfriend when like first
of all Sabrina didn't like steal
anyone's boyfriend it was just like the
next girl and like I feel like it's a
very new
age tale or feminism to like support
both of these girls because like they're
both really talented artists and neither
of them like did anything wrong to one
another and I feel like even like Olivia
would say that you know like there's I
think Olivia would say that I don't
think Sabrina would say that right the
only person who should really be pissed
here is Sabrina
right like Sabrina had like a whole
smear campaign against her when all she
did was like like some kid who was like
11. and it got because I like the boy
isn't that her song yeah all because I
liked him but like all because she liked
a boy so yeah Olivia Rodrigo can be like
copacetic with everyone but that's easy
to say when the world didn't turn on you
in an instant yeah
Sabrina Carpenter probably is mad and
has every right to be mad
yeah but where there's honestly there's
something going on I'm serious like this
is weird there's something else but but
I do agree with you like Taylor's so
like new age feminist like so evolved
passes she wouldn't like have beef with
someone and then go be with Sabrina
Carpenter like I get it and she also but
it's weird penalized Sabrina because
she's friends with Olivia and they
happen to date the same person like
that's just why are we gonna blame women
no but you agree like there's something
weird about this whole thing the weirder
part is not only Olivia Rodrigo and
Taylor are like going so hard and then
not though that kind of seems to be a
pattern for Taylor like
hailee Steinfeld we were just talking
about
yeah I guess she like has like
friendship
um eras yeah which is fine I think
people do that
um but also like Olivia Rodrigo where
this is quiet is she is quiet yeah she's
been quiet someone actually messaged me
something the other day about like it
was a video of something like how this
girl like popped off took over the world
like and like
everyone obsessed with her song and like
where is she
yeah I mean
I know she I don't think she's on the
new season of that High School Musical
show okay I think she's like
fully embracing like her pop star era
she did a very small tour after like
this worldwide
obsession with her music she didn't like
add more dates do bigger venues she like
did the tour and then went very M.I.A
like I feel like she's probably working
on new music but like she she's not also
like participating in well she was at
the Met Gala
yeah but still like where was she I
didn't see her no she's quiet she's just
she's quiet
she's fading
yeah intentionally or unintentionally I
don't know it feels a little it feels
intentional yeah yeah maybe it was too
much I mean it's the Addison effect
right our Queen yeah
yeah so that's just interesting no it is
speaking of interesting beef are you
ready for our next story is it the
interesting beef that happens to be
brought to you by Master Class yeah
with masterclass you can learn from the
best to become your best anytime
anywhere and at your own pace so they
have annual memberships that start at
ten dollars a month and you get
unlimited access to every instructor
thousands of online lessons exclusive
content insights and much more I have to
say masterclassic really has some of the
most premier A-list Talent teaching
their classes like of course if you
watch the Kardashians you know that Kris
Jenner did one that was really well
received Gordon Ramsay has one Malcolm
Gladwell Steve Martin Esther perel
Mariah Carey so whatever it is that
you're like looking for like for me I
definitely go on the platform and look
for like more like social marketing
influencer Vibes but if you want to get
into cooking I mean Gordon Ramsay
teaching you and you don't have to like
actually be in his presence so he can't
call you enemy names like how fabulous
is this of Both Worlds
there are over 180 classes to pick from
you can find practical takeaways that
you can apply to your life and at work
if you run a business you can use
masterclass to help your team this is
one of those things that just like as an
adult is a really good use of your time
it's also really entertaining to see
people you idolize and love just sit
down and talk to and give you all their
secrets so you can gain new skills in as
little as 10 minutes either on your
phone computer Tablet Smart TV and even
in audio mode to listen on the go for
all of our podcast girlies how much
would it cost to take one-on-one classes
from the world's best well with
masterclass and their annual membership
it would only cost ten dollars a month
get unlimited access to every class and
right now as a toast listener you can
get 15 off when you go to
masterclass.com toast that's
masterclass.com toast for 15 off an
annual membership
masterclass.com toast that's a really
exciting new sponsor I feel like
everybody loves masterclass it's also an
amazing gift I gave it as a gift to
someone who is an aspiring actor because
they not only have master classes from
actors on acting from directors from
screenwriters like you could learn the
whole industry from the comfort of your
bed and 30 what do we love about bed
what I think a better question is what
don't we love about Ben
Trails today's episode is also brought
to you by our favorite the perfect bar
the original refrigerated protein bar
that you know and love and if you
haven't heard perfect bar just launched
a new line of protein bars called
perfect bar layers that Jackie was
actually eating in the doctor's office
this morning I was I had one in my
pocket throughout the day
perfect bar layers are a new line of
crispy protein bars that are stacked
with three delicious layers and packed
with whole food nutrition they're made
with a crispy base of peanut butter and
cashew butter they're layered with dark
chocolate or 100 real fruit and then
they're sprinkled with toasted
gluten-free oats they're packed with up
to 11 grams of protein and they come in
two delicious flavors crispy peanut
butter and chocolate and a crispy peanut
butter and Berry which is basically like
a healthy peanut butter and jelly
they're made with only whole food
ingredients which means that they are
stored in the fridge which is just kind
of a relief and makes you question every
other bar that's not stored in the
fridge their classic blend of 20 organic
superfoods and they also contain no
artificial preservatives if you aren't
convinced already they're also non-GMO
project verified gluten-free soy-free
kosher and low GI the best part is that
you can now find them in the
refrigerated section at Target
Nationwide perfect bar knows that it'll
be Love At First Bite so they're
offering you a chance to try their new
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
texts and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or your PayPal account which is
pretty cool all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking happy snacking
I had that peanut butter and jelly one
yesterday and it was magden
mad good bro next up Shark Tank star
Damon John files for a restraining order
against former contestants this is crazy
Damon John has filed for a temporary
restraining order against former
contestants hold on I'm having such a
bad heartburn
okay you want me to edit this out no no
I'll be back I'll be back breathe
through your nose you want a tum or
something they're over Yonder I'm good
I'm good it was just a passing thing I
just didn't want to keep like
no like choking on your words I
understand yeah yeah yeah
um after they claimed that he tried to
cut them out of their due profits the
celebrity investor Damon requested the
order against al Bubba Baker his wife
Sabrina Baker and their daughter
Brittany Beau Baker who have publicly
claimed that Damon John attempted to
overtake their Bubba's Q boneless baby
back ribs truck David I just want to say
I remember these people me too Damon
spokesperson Zach Rosenfield denied the
claims made by the baker family and
explained why his client is pursuing
such an extreme request according to
Rosenfield there have been there have
been repeated attempts to give the
Bakers the ability to correct their
violations it is unfortunate that it has
come to this this temporary restraining
order is due to the baker's blatant
actions to undermine a Business
Partnership and the legal parameters
they agreed to four years ago their
belief that they can unwind poor
business decisions through slanderous
social media posts and articles will no
longer be tolerated
damn by the way this is messy and you
know what's so interesting is that this
really has not happened with any sharks
and their Investments like I think I I
I'm gonna I think side with Damon John
on this just because he's like a track
record of being like a good in
in not whatsoever Integrity is that a
word like when you have integrity like
Integrity integral integral but that
means something different Integrity
filled
Integrity filled like business person I
think a lot of people he has many
successes from Shark Tank so if there
was like a
a history of him like exploiting small
businesses and taking over first of all
I don't know if you know of all the
things he's invested in would he try and
take over
a
ribs truck I think his most it
his most valuable
uh investment was that comb that ended
up getting like licensed by all these
companies like he if he was going to
take over he was going to take over
something much bigger yeah I agree I'm
intended to
um side with Damon I think I don't think
we have any idea like what happened the
LA Times had reported that the Bakers
claimed that they were offered 300 000
for 30 of the company when they were on
the show but then they went on like
Damon went on to revise the terms of the
investment instead offering a hundred
thousand dollars for 35 percent of the
company and he also wanted to take the
company into business with rastelli
Foods Group but that's kind of congress
with what we know about Shark Tank I
feel like so many of the deals fall
through and it wouldn't be surprising if
a deal changes after the show because
then they do get to see like actual
paperwork like on the show you could say
oh I did this much in Revenue but then
when you go to sign the deal like if it
doesn't add up you don't get a deal but
maybe like the deal just changes too you
know the deals that they make in the
Shark Tank are predicated on everything
that person pitched being 100 true and
it's not like once they shake hands like
the deal is done they act actually like
do all the paperwork and the people who
are business owners have to provide like
Yeah we actually did do two million
dollars last year and if they lied or
they fudged some numbers like their
valuation goes down and then that makes
the investor want to change their deal
and I think if you're like a true Shark
Tank fan you know that a 50 of the deals
that are made on TV actually don't even
go through and afterwards they're
subject to change yeah also I think it's
not even like about lying but when you
and any business like you have so many
papers you have so many numbers like
maybe you didn't it didn't come up how
much how many employees you have and how
much salary that you had some debt yeah
yeah yeah like things just don't come up
there you get to see a hundred percent
what the business is and is that what
you thought it was they are able to go
back on their initial offer so
again I'm with you like Damon has a very
good track record this is one out of
many deals that's gone yeah that it's
the only one that's gone South it seems
so
um I also don't think he would take such
big like uh
steps in like strong yeah such a strong
reaction if he was in the wrong like I
feel like he'd just make it go away yeah
I'm inclined to to side with Damon on
this one yeah but very interesting yes
our fifth and final story is a little
Biz news that I find so interesting that
oh yeah it's the perfect Friday Fifth
and Final it is because we're good
stories Jackie thank you what they were
good stories today right they were
saying they were giving they were giving
story they were giving it's giving story
yeah the New York Post published an
article yesterday saying that your
favorite takeout joint is actually a
catfishing scam and it's totally legal
so they did this whole write-up on this
Bodega type restaurant it's called
Gourmet Deli there's one in the city
it's on 90th Street and First Avenue and
from the outside it seems like every
other Deli spread across the city on a
typical morning various locals pop in
for bacon bacon egg and cheese
sandwiches coffee but another wave of
customers is flooding in through food
delivery apps only they don't know
they're ordering from a bodega the deli
located on First Avenue is advertised as
no less than 27 different restaurants
across ubereats Postmates GrubHub
seamless and doordash on those platforms
it's listed as all as 27 different
things I'm going to read you some so you
can see what they're doing one First
Avenue Gourmet Deli next hero sandwich
shop next boss cat cheesesteaks next the
pancake snob next wraps on tap next
insomnia Buffalo Wings by the way I
would 100 order from a place called raps
on tap no I know they're like they sell
all these things at their huge Deli so
they've sectioned it out to be like a
glitzier idea you have something because
honestly I don't know that I would order
from Gourmet Deli I would not but I
might order from Tina's tea shop I would
definitely order from Sandwich [__] this
sandwich [__] is here Empire State
Panini Seth's sandwiches who's Seth I
don't know I don't care no Jackie I have
to say this should not be illegal and
it's not it is the most genius thing and
it also it kind of TAPS into like
you know user culture on these apps like
you're so persuaded by like the
restaurant's name and like their
pictures even if you've never been to
this place you've never heard of this
place there's like a formula in the
algorithm that'll get you this is
brilliant like I have to say I am beyond
impressed to me I think some people are
like this is you know just set deceitful
I think this is the smartest [__]
thing I've ever heard in my life this is
just smart business like some small
business owner being resourceful like
seeing what's going on in the
marketplace and adjusting also what's
also interesting is that the prices for
everything change is based on where
you're ordering from also versus if you
go into the store so princess Panini
Empire State Panini and Panini fantasy
which are all gourmet Telly Panini they
all offer a tuna melt for 16 to 17 But
First Avenue Gourmet Deli sells theirs
for nine dollars but they really are
tapping into like this like aesthetic
the way that people are so like caught
up with like pictures and how things
look like I think they're just playing
the game they are living in the future
my friend I and you know what you and I
love to order from this ghost Kitchen
yes well so this is the article says
that um for a while all of these places
were confused with ghost kitchens
because ghost kitchens popped up during
the pandemic they sprang up as like
businesses in brick and mortar spaces
that only do delivery so it's not a
restaurant you can't go in there but
they like took over old restaurants just
a commercial kitchen and they rented a
new crew to do delivery only kitchen and
there is one ghost kitchen that we love
so much and the thing is the delivery
comes good because it's made for
delivery like honestly I'd rather order
from a ghost kitchen than order from
Nobu it comes like [__] because they
don't care about their delivery they're
not a delivery business no ghost
kitchens are genius but now I'm
definitely suspicious yeah well though
like so ghost kitchens are a separate
thing where like that is a restaurant
there's only one of them this is I guess
like some sort of digital eats
catfishing I just think they're playing
chess no if I could meet the man or
woman whose idea this was like I would
shake their hand it's so genius it's so
genius and as long as the food so the
only criticism that people have which I
guess you could say is like uh
legit is that um
the it kind of violates some health code
stuff because most delis and bodegas in
the city are classified as stores
supermarkets and man and food
manufacturers and they're regulated by
New York State's Department of
Agriculture and markets not the
department of health and mental hygiene
so they're not like they have different
rating systems for like cleanliness and
stuff in a supermarket versus a
restaurant so I guess there's like more
open to uh issues
um like the letter grades and expense
inspections aren't the same I don't care
but I don't care
no I love I literally love this what's
also interesting is in this article they
said that in some cases chain
restaurants that you know like Denny's
lists itself as a different brand to
appeal to more customers
um online for delivery only like Denny's
has delivery only called the Meltdown
okay I have experienced this not in New
York always when I'm on tour and I'm
like the room service in the hotel is
closed I'll go to ubereats and I'm like
oh I've never heard of this I ordered
like okay I ordered like a grilled
chicken sandwich from like this cool it
was called like American Pub it was just
like bar food
I literally got it the bag and I opened
it and all the rap like the wrapper on
the sandwich the bag was Red Robin
wow and you know what I didn't even care
because it was literally one of the best
sandwiches I've ever had yeah that's the
thing like if it's good it's good if it
arrives like the pictures say like then
okay so you got played sorry you got
played but it's so interesting but did
you even like
you got your sandwich you got what you
asked for a second for a second I
thought I got the wrong order because
I'm like did I order from Red Robin
and I checked and I didn't and I was
like damn well I can't get I can't
communicate with the guy because the
order is over let me see what this
person ordered and it was quite
literally what I ordered that's how I
realized I had been catfished but it was
okay with you it's like maybe you get
catfished sometimes by someone that you
actually are attracted to we're meant to
be with and like would love
and it's yeah it's a happy ending it was
a happy ending for me and my Red Robin
sandwich and you know what I don't think
at that point I had ever had Red Robin
and now everyone was [__] good Red
Robin's Red Robin
no I was definitely hooked on Red Robin
and then it was like your biases were
stopping you from ordering from there so
they needed to Rebrand
quite literally yeah and like I could
see myself I wouldn't order from Gourmet
Deli but like princess Panini like I'm
hungry no it's Jackie I'm telling you
when you sent me this article yesterday
I was obsessed I think this is the best
idea on the planet no this is a smart
businessman or woman who is playing the
hand that they're dealt yeah and I love
it and this tweet at the end sums it up
for me whatever man is the food good did
you die oh right then gonna order [__]
notes [__] so true
this is a really good stories thank you
let us know what you think about
catfishing restaurants but you know what
they should do next at Gourmet Deli they
should inside have like a little
sign that says princess paninis next the
sandwich [__] like and also known as
also known as they should really change
the name of their Deli to also known as
and like a little annoyed at the near
post for blowing up their spot I know
but they gave us something to talk about
and I'm obsessed
how I can like really feel like the
ingenue and American creativity like is
not gone no we're back on track baby
America First this person should be head
of the economy
agreed yeah
so those are the stories that was your
show that was your week and it was
fabulous next week is still very much up
in the air Jax is going to take it day
by day we'll see how she feels on Monday
we'll probably do a mix of audio only
been on the toast satch on the toast
Taylor on the toast if that's okay with
everyone that's okay with me I'm here to
do audio only but I know turdy's got to
be seen she's got a CNB scene
no I'm literally seeing NBC but we'll do
like the Monday post and post Vanderpump
for sure will be us like the big oh
that's a good call Monday and Thursday
definitely Jackson Claude yeah but you
never know I also like love you on
Wednesdays because of your toasters but
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
Monday Wednesday Thursday sounds good to
me
hope you guys have an amazing weekend
again thanks for your patience uh this
week and today with the delayed episode
we love you dearly thanks so much for
listening to the Tesla Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the Five Star
Stories that you need to know everybody
do Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available at
Spotify June Central Public video I read
a ghost box all the places
we are have an amazing weekend we love
you and we'll see you on Monday love you
bye